while we are experiencing supply chain
issues consumer confidence and demand is
very high as is the outlook for the
upcoming holiday season this according
to the retail association of nevada
[Music]
income
is actually up for nevadans and then
americans in general and so there's a
strong resilience to
spend
savings are also up brian wachter of the
retail association of nevada says he's
expecting a robust holiday season as we
start moving into november every
retailer is making sure they can meet
customers where they want to be met
whether it's online shopping curbside
pickup or in the store we are actually
importing and have more products now
than we had in 2019 or in 2020 at this
time so inventories are up but we may
still see snags in our supply chain due
to the backlog at the ports and the
trucker driver shortage creating less
variety and limited choices the key
while you're out shopping don't forget
your patience the holiday season can
create some anxiety and especially as
there may be some empty shelves we just
want to caution everyone have some
patience
make sure that the retail workers that
are there
we're being courteous to them as they
start a very challenging time as well